okay we're gonna start it's already half
past so it is my pleasure to introduce
the last but not least keynote speaker
of Pi Londinium 2019 we have Brandon
Rhodes with us here he's coming all the
way from Ohio which we are very grateful
for thank you very much
he's a Python programmer he was a Pike
on us chair and I don't want to say
you're more of your time because I know
you have lots of interesting since to
say so over to you thank you and I want
to thank the organizers I want to thank
the organizers very much for inviting me
it's been at least half a decade no you
know half a decade been been five years
or more since I first got to visit
London and I've really enjoyed my visit
and I've really enjoyed the energy of
the conference and especially how
compared to other conferences I've been
to in Britain how many different places
you are all from I've enjoyed meeting
you and I'm here to talk about
typesetting with Python when I was
growing up there was a book on my
father's bookshelf he was an electrical
engineer it attracted me because of the
interesting design of its cover which
showed an ancient way of trying to
design the letter s it was by someone
had never heard of named Donald e Knuth
and it was called HEC and meta font not
text and meta font no he named the
typesetting system that he wrote after
the Greek word techne they had the same
word in Greek for both a craft and an
art and so he named his typesetting
system not with the letter X but with
the Greek letter Chi as its third letter
tech it introduced me as I read through
the book and he explained its work
they introduced me to the idea of a
markup language I'd never heard of such
a thing instead of being in an a WYSIWYG
editor you just wrote plain text that
you were completely in control of and
then tech read the plain text and turned
it into a document
you had to learn some conventions some
commands that started with back slashes
and the proper use of curly braces but
you got to write plain text without
thinking much about how it would be laid
out on the page and the text system
swung into action and made it look like
I could professionally typeset paragraph
from a book the books lessons on how to
type these dot tech input files were
themselves a small course in typography
you learned where to put non-breaking
spaces because it turns out it is a
minor typographic disaster if a title
like dr. or mr. or mrs. ends one line of
a paragraph separated from the name on
the next line so I learned about
non-breaking spaces I learned that these
four pieces of punctuation are
completely different and it is entirely
wrong to use any of them for the others
purpose the - the end - the M - and the
minus sign look different in the case of
the minus sign are at a different height
on the line and have completely
different purposes you will be
frequently annoyed for the rest of your
life
if you learn the difference and again
it's markup language even though all you
had was ASCII keys back in the 70s there
was a way to separately type each of
those symbols into your input file its
specialty was math typesetting Donald
Knuth was a mathematician and that was
the real reason for inventing Tec when
math journals stopped paying for
professionals to expensively set type by
hand math papers looked so ugly that
Knuth could no longer publish to survive
as a mathematician he had to remedy the
situation so that he could stand seeing
his equations in print and so he took an
entire year off I believe it was 78
might have been 77 to invent Tec and so
its specialty is inside of dollar signs
you have a little language that kicks in
underscore a subscript carrot is
superscript where you can just say I'll
take the sum from k equals 0 to infinity
and out comes beautifully typeset math
that look to me like something from an
expensive professional math book it was
a beautiful system Peregrine he did not
ignore non math problems like breaking
paragraphs into lines Tec represents the
words of a paragraph as fixed width
fixed width boxes separated by stretchy
glue because to lay out a paragraph you
try to make the lines the same length by
stretching or shrinking those spaces
this internal representation of the
problem of breaking a paragraph into
lines well it has a combinatorial
problem a paragraph within positions at
which text could be split into lines can
be laid out to to the in different ways
depending on whether you take each break
or not how could we ever find the
optimum way out I'll bet you thought
dynamic programming existed only to be a
whiteboard problem in interviews Donald
Knuth actually found dynamic programming
could solve that problem and provide the
optimal solution for breaking each
paragraph
two lines in an N squared worst case
actually usually only on the order of
the number of possible breaks so you put
in a plain text it turned it into boxes
and glue and it managed to beautifully
line up that right hand side of each
paragraph just like in a book the output
of Tec was beautiful but as I then some
day I eventually had a computer powerful
powerful enough to run it I found it was
difficult to control once you set up the
parameters layout proceeded largely
outside of your control it reminded me
of a problem that I've seen recently
which is the tractor and trailer problem
tractor has a motoring can move forward
and back and the trailers are simply
passive if you've ever tried backing up
a single trailer it can be difficult
they often today consider for factory
floors and things like that two three
four trailers if you've ever tried to
back up a small toy train you might have
an idea of the difficulty here backing
up a trailer a tractor in trailers is
today an open problem in AI you can find
recent papers that talk about could we
back up three tryout trailers with an
appropriate AI trailers are difficult to
back up because the input the motion of
the tractor has an increasingly distant
relationship to the motion of the in
trailer and that problem trying to
control tech sometimes felt similar and
in general I would say that frameworks
in programming and I use that term in
its fully perative sense frameworks
often have the same problem that you
feel like there's this little opinion
you've been asked for and it can be very
hard to get the form that they forms
library outputs to respond to the
settings that you're trying to change
controlling text felt similar so I had
an idea what if instead of typesetting
systems that we merely configure and
then run off and do their thing what if
there were a typesetting library that
left the programmer in control for
difficult situations that you might want
to customize recently I realized that
typesetting and printing a book from
Python was coming within technical reach
there's now an industry called print on
demand
all you need to give them is a PDF and
they can send you back a custom
hardcover book that is all yours
a real hardcover case found and Smith's
own not something just put together with
glue
we now have technologies that largely
replace all the things Donald Knuth had
to invent on his own
we now have TrueType and OpenType we
don't have to invent the idea of vector
fonts instead of a macro language there
are many ways to represent paragraphs
and headings and plain text I didn't
even need to implement paragraph layout
Andrew couch Lee translated that boxes
and glue algorithm into Python long ago
and called it Tech lib and we don't need
to use Tex custom DVI output format PDFs
are now the industry standard but I
needed something to print this is the
problem with little projects that you
dream about and then I stumbled across a
backup of my grandfather's essays which
after he died in the 90s I'd backed up
off of his computer I could write the
typesetting myself in Python and have a
gift to give to family members a
hardback of his thoughts and memories
and history so alright we're going to be
reimplemented tech what would I do
differently if I'm gonna try to do
layout over again what's the thing I
want to focus on I chose a specific
first goal to see if I could not just to
re-implement it but do something
interestingly different what about
different width columns as you're laying
out the document that's not supported in
tech it wants each column to be the same
width as tech breaks a paragraph into
lines it doesn't even know what page the
paragraph will land on because first it
splits the paragraph into lines at some
width
that's a separate step from then
figuring out how many lines of the
paragraph fit on each page so you can't
support graphic designs that have one
width on the first page of your
newspaper and maybe a different column
width on the inside
you can't support graphic designers that
on the front page of the article have a
single wide column to accommodate an
image but then on the inside have a
double column my idea was that the
paragraph should ask for more space as
it needs it so it learns about any width
change when it asks for more space and
has to cross to a new column I wanted to
see if I could get that working because
that would be a real advance over what
tech had been able to do so my plan was
to find a library for rendering PDF from
Python and then invent a new page layout
engine I decided to tackle them in that
order I had already used to make a I
think a program of a printed program for
a conference I'd use report lab it's a
PDF library in Python and so I hooked it
up to Andrew couch Ling's Tech lib and I
printed out the first paragraph of my
grandfather's first essay about his
great-grandfather in 1800s Alabama and
the result as you can see was a disaster
on what yes we're just going to have to
stop right here this is the best that we
can do and the interestingly enough when
I use this font on the web I double
checked it the word war looked fine
report lab specifically as a library
doesn't understand that TrueType and
OpenType fonts come with a table a
kerning table that tells you that some
letters need to be pushed closer
together or they'll leave a gap it
didn't know about kerning so the word
war is an unmitigated disaster here
fortunately it turns out there was an
alternative I'd always thought that the
Qt library was kind of a useless way to
write big bloated desktop applications
but it turns out that desktop
applications need a print button
and so cutie has an entire PDF rendering
engine inside of it thank goodness
reads the metrics of a font before
putting it on the page all right so I
have my PDF library I was moving again
the input is going to be from however my
text is stored a list of typesetting
actions titles headings and paragraphs
and now I simply need to design the
routine that will run through them
putting them on the page what API should
the layout engine use to call each of
these actions like heading and paragraph
well let's start by asking what
information doesn't actually need if
we're gonna set it loose laying out
content on page well I thought it would
need to know the width of the text it's
expected to layout we need to probably
know the height of the column so I wrap
that up and do a little object and then
it probably needs to know how much of
the columns being used already it needs
to know the y-coordinate that it should
start at as it adds more content each
time the paragraph needs another line it
can look at the amount of letting it
needs used to be a little sheet of lead
that you put in between each line of
type today it's just a little blank
space to give a nice line height not
crowd the text too much vertically and
the fonts height and if the current
y-coordinate plus the letting it needs
to add plus the size of the font it
needs to add is going to be more than
the columns height we're out of room we
ask for another column how do we ask for
another column
I had several possibilities I could try
here maybe the column itself has a
method called next maybe we've has a
layout object that can give you new
columns as you asked for them or I could
just pass a next column callable number
of different options I decided to pass a
plain callable and I knew it was the
right decision when I did it and that
wouldn't have been true when I was a
younger programmer I knew that if all
the paragraph needs is a verb a next
column that spits out new columns that's
all that I should pass it why to avoid I
decided I needed a name for it
premature object-orientation there is an
old saying in computer scientist
computer science premature optimization
is the root of all evil
who said that donald knuth
i didn't know that till i looked it up
premature object-orientation which is my
phrase is attaching a verb gratuitously
to a noun when you don't actually need
to yet the symptom is when you see code
passing an object on which a function
will only ever call a single method this
is the symptom you're given an object
why all you ever do is call that single
method why not just pass the verb
instead premature object-orientation
couples code aids only a verb to all the
implementation details of the noun
because you receive the whole thing and
so because of some restraint that I've
learned over my career I simply passed
the collarbone next column that
generates new space in the document I
now had a rough plan for an actions
inputs all right what now will in action
return can for example a paragraph
simply go ahead and draw on the output
device no it turns out it cannot because
there are a number of problems which I
can illustrate by talking about headings
heading is supposed to sit atop the
content of widgets the head yes that's
why it's called a heading it looks sort
of like this this is a paragraph laid
out by my oh and ER couch Ling's Tech
lib library called by mine and paragraph
paragraph ends and we have just enough
room on this page for the heading and a
line of text what if there's no room
beneath a heading what if the column
were a little smaller well then you get
a typographic disaster if the column
weren't high enough for that line the
heading would stand by itself not
heading anything the heading in that
case is going to need to move itself to
the next column far better to have a
little blank space at the bottom of a
column
than to have a heading that doesn't have
any content beneath it now you might
think that that's going to be easy to
avoid can the headings simply check
whether there is room for an extra line
beneath it but checking for a free line
won't alas always work why because a
paragraph might not choose to use the
final line of a column because if
something paragraphs do on their own
they're tricky beasts called widow and
orphan detection a single line paragraph
might deign to remain at the bottom of
the page and then our heading has
something to head before the text moves
to the next column but a multi-line
paragraph will refuse to leave its
opening line alone will refuse to leave
it an orphan it will look and say I
can't leave that line by itself that's
considered a sin in typography so even
if there's the space for a line a
multi-line paragraph will pull it up to
the top of the next page to look better
leaving the heading stranded even though
it looked like there was enough room for
more content well okay if paragraphs are
going to do tricky interior things
decisions about where they land where
how can the heading predict whether it
will be stranded alone well it can
either know everything about paragraphs
and have insight of it all of the
details about how paragraphs layout that
doesn't sound wise or sustainable or I
could invent a way for a heading to ask
the next action to lay itself out
speculatively and just kind of ask well
if I stay here at the bottom of the page
what paragraph will you do next but this
is going to require undo the ability if
layout goes wrong if I wind up stranded
to back up because the headings going to
have to add itself to the document and
the following paragraph and if it worked
if there are some if having done that
there are some lines of text beneath the
heading we're done if the heading finds
that it wound up stranded and alone
you're gonna have to undo the paragraph
undo the heading start over again on the
next
Paige that means these routines cannot
be writing to the PDF manually layout is
going to need to return an intermediate
data structure that the caller can
inspect instead of just starting to
write type all over our document
consequence number two is that the
intermediate data needs to be easy to
discard I went through several pencil
and paper I don't even try writing code
on at the stage of design I have tried
to figure out what relationship would
let me add stuff to a document plan that
I could then just take away and I was
startled to discover that a very elegant
data structure for it was one I had
never used in Python in Python I used a
linked list I defined a line as not only
belonging to a column having a
y-coordinate and then having some
graphics that if you decide to keep the
line you draw on the page but I gave it
a previous attribute which as I go down
the page I said each lines not previous
to the line above it thus creating a
linked list of lines that when I need to
stop and make a decision I can run a
paragraphs layout one way look at those
lines run it another way and the two
possible futures for my document
automatically share this storage all the
previous document without my having to
store it twice because they both share a
reference to it a linked list lets us
extend the document with any number of
speculative layout speculative layouts
which Python automatically disposes of
as we discard them actions okay are now
going to need a new argument because if
they're going if their job the job of an
action is now to append new lines they
need is an argument the most recently
laid out line before the action goes to
work ooh
but look remember how a paragraph needs
to know the column it's drawing in and
the wide position so far those are two
attributes of the line itself I didn't
know I'd be passing lines in as an
argument
but now that I know that this gets
passed in I no longer need to separately
pass in the column and the y-coordinate
the paragraph learns everything about
the current context merely by looking at
this line object that I didn't even pass
in for its own amusement I passed it in
because it needs to append more lines
but it wound up carrying almost all the
information the paragraph needs in other
words designing our return value wound
up eliminating two of our input
arguments always look for chances to
simplify as you proceed with a design
it's often pleasant how the how things
simplify as you go along another nice
thing is the symmetry that this concept
of a line provides the line becomes a
common currency that's both our argument
we get one line passed in and our return
value is we return a new terminal line
back out all right but how will the
heading action invoke the action that
follows I haven't talked yet about how
the heading talks to the paragraph and
how will it tell the engine of the
following actions already laid out if
the heading needs to lay out the
paragraph it needs to tell the engine
hey I've already laid out the paragraph
don't do it over again now that I hand
back control and return of value
once again pencil and paper I looked at
special callable and exception should
these two things be coatings that talk
to each other I took a deep breath all
right now I looked at the reality of
however I arranged the conversation
between the heading and the paragraph
the real reality is that I just have a
list of tuples of things that I need to
put on the page and so I thought of
something kind of radical what if I just
passed the list into the heading and the
current I know that sounds crazy you'd
think I would hide it behind something
but what if in this case I just tailed a
heading the truth hey there's a list of
actions your at position a go to town
and when you return the concluding line
from all the work you've done tell me
how far to advance my counter before
continuing incrementing and returning
the a index
what's an action invoke as many
subsequent actions as it needs to
to compare different outcomes so
stepping back I wrote several routines
to that spec I looked askance at the
amount of repetition in my code that
this created heading took actions in a
section took actions in a both used them
but a paragraph which doesn't care about
the subsequent action also takes actions
as nna as did other simple routines they
just kept returning a plus-one because I
laid myself out continued and seemed a
bit verbose for opinionated actions my
headings that care about what follows
it's necessary to pass actions and a so
that they can get to the next thing but
simple actions that just lay themselves
out and don't care about what comes next
ignore them and so the simple actions at
the bottom are receiving parameters they
don't really need how can I eliminate
actions in a from simple actions that
don't need them this is a principle in
programming called
dry don't repeat yourself and when I
thought of those words I suddenly heard
the call of distant decades the 1990s
called and said practices back in the
90s that all in Python I can introspect
functions to learn if they take actions
arguments or not so given a list of
functions I can just leave actions off
of these argument lists and use pythons
introspection abilities to know whether
to pass those arguments or not the 90s
crazy times up then the early 2000s
called I could have a special registry
kis functions or objects and can be
enrolled in data structures I could have
a registry for functions that don't need
actions an a so I know to call them
differently the late-2000s called I
could have a decorator for functions
that don't need actions in a that takes
those two parameters but doesn't pass
them to the function being wrapped all I
would then need to do is put that
decorator in front of each of my simpler
routines and I wouldn't have those extra
parameters
don't repeat yourself so I looked at the
different possibilities that Python
makes possible and what did I decide I
decided to repeat myself I decided after
several minutes - probably about a half
hour of deliberation trying different
things out maybe a bourbon
I made the radical and countercultural
decision to simply pass actions and ate
every single routine why because of
symmetry everything looks the same
if I pass actions and a when I return to
code months and years later I relearned
my code by rereading it given a stack of
functions that do exactly the same thing
if half of them use one convention and
half of them use another then I now have
twice the number of conventions to
relearn later and only half the number
example of examples of each to relearn
from so I would not have done this when
I was younger I just chose verbose
symmetry over a symmetric brevity which
would always have been my choice earlier
in my career as a reader I need routines
that behave the same to look the same if
I have a chance of being able to
maintain my own software and so symmetry
it remained I simply had all the
routines follow the same API all right
we're ready for a final design step I
talked earlier about widows and orphans
avoiding stranding the first or last
paragraph of a line alone as a human
with intelligence laying out type was
done for hundreds of years in Europe how
does that look in code
well my paragraph routine was was a bit
complicated because of widows and
orphans a paragraph had to lay itself
out if it stranded an orphan at the page
bottom it had to go back and try all
over again
lay itself out if it there's then
stranded a widow at the top of the next
page had to try again
inside of this if-else widow/orphan
logic paragraph had a hidden simpler
inner routine called repeatedly that did
the actual paragraph layout you couldn't
get to it it was down at the bottom of
all these ifs and else's so what if you
had wanted to just call the simple
paragraph layout routine well I had to
start adding boolean options to the
paragraph callable in order to turn on
and off that outer level of if
statements but boolean switches are
often a hint that we have coupled what
could actually be two different routines
instead of stranding code inside of
other code with a switch to turn it on
and off can you pull it out separately
composition when it's possible is always
to be preferred over coupling and so if
a heading it occurred to me can control
things about the paragraph that follows
it could I write and avoid widows and
orphans routine that had no content of
its own to offer to the page but that
simply controlled the next item whatever
it was to help it avoid the problem of
stranding lines I thought through it
avoiding an orphan easy here on the left
a paragraph has stranded an orphan its
first line at the bottom of a page all
we need to do if a paragraph does that
is have this previous action go ahead
and use up with whitespace the bottom of
the first page then let the paragraph
layout it's very very easy to bump an
orphan to the next page and fix it
before calling the paragraph simply move
to the next column
what about avoiding a widow I tried to
sketch out a solution and found it is
nearly impossible why well because a
widow is created when the very last line
of the paragraph falls onto a separate
Paige this means I have to lay out the
paragraph all over again and it's next
to the last line even though there's
room for it in the column needs to
decide to move to the next page how am I
going in the middle of the paragraph
making decisions to just convince it to
not use the page like it's supposed to
and move to the next column how would we
ever convince a paragraph to move to the
next column early I went and looked at
the inside of the paragraph in each time
the paragraph needs another line letting
the height adds them together compares
them to the column height and it's that
trigger I need so much space and it's
not available that convinces it to ask
for another column how could we
influence this choice well I could lie
about the value of y I could create a
line object that I pass it that has a Y
that's a little bigger than it should be
so the paragraph will run out of room
early but then I'll have to go and fix
all the line objects it returns to be
back up where they belong on the page I
could make a fake column object instead
of the real column object it's a little
shorter than normal and thus forced the
routine to move to the next page early
we are looking desperately for
parameters to tweak why because we're
standing outside of the code that makes
the decision so all of the ideas I was
thinking of we're really bad ones it was
it was that feeling of using a framework
you're not quite in control of your
thinking of what parameter can I
possibly set here that will make the
paragraph behave like I want we're on
the outside is that really where we want
to be during our codes crucial decision
know when code is making a crucial
decision you want to be in the room
where it happens the room where it
happens the room where it happens
I want to be in the room where it
happens right now the paragraph only
consults us when it needs a whole new
column right if it needs another page
another column it calls the callback
that we've provided it well what if I
get this concept which actually was
repeated all through my code of needing
another line comparing and seeing if I
have enough room and either returning a
line in the same column or if we run out
of room a line in the next column what
if I wrap that up as a collar ball and
so what if the paragraph calls back not
only when it thinks it needs a next
column what if instead of only calling
me back when it thinks it's ready for
the next column the paragraph calls back
every time it needs a next line what if
I get that crucial if statement I need
to control that's down in the paragraphs
own code and bump it up into a callable
that I pass in then the widow/orphan
logic can subvert the paragraphs normal
decision simply by passing a custom next
line function right inside of avoid
widows and orphans I can just make a
little wrapper and pass the wrapped
version of next line to paragraph and
I'm in complete control of exactly the
point at which it decides to go ask for
the next column and moves to the top of
that page this design was a complete
success and completely let me break out
widow and orphan avoidance from
paragraphs and turn it into a general
routine which can apply to bulleted
lists to tables to all kinds of
information that I might want to apply
the same logic to but did you catch why
this approach is a success why why was I
able to do this sleight of hand
the fancy next line wrapper is so simple
because we avoided premature object
Orion
datian what if instead of just passing
next line we were passed a whole layout
object and next line was merely a method
how would you make an object's an
already existing objects next line
method returned a different value
because you wanted it to when you monkey
patch it would you wrap it in an adapter
class would you implement the entire
gang of 4 decorator pattern in object
orientation customizing a verb
one little verb can retry require
trundling out an entire design pattern
to wrap the object but if you pass
collar balls
if you treat your verbs as first-class
citizens which is one of the strengths
of Python simple inline wrapper can put
you in the room where it happens I've
learned over the years in my designs to
start verbose and don't be afraid of
that and to simplify and collapse things
down later I have come despite myself to
value symmetry over special cases to
avoid premature object orientation and
to let verbs be first class citizens
attach them to nouns only if there's a
compelling reason like dynamic dispatch
I plan if you want to look at some of
this code parts of it work on release
ink by typesetting Python library later
this summer but you can already watch my
progress on github among other things it
laid out this entire presentation which
is a PDF and so to conclude what was
that book that I showed you a picture of
earlier that is my grandfather's memoirs
the story the family history going back
to the 1820s his opinions on religion
and politics and death all bound
together in a hardback book sure print
and design in Toronto Canada will print
runs of as little as two books I wanted
to hold it in my hand and proofread it
and have a copy to give my father
so we got every anything anything we
needed to fixed before we handed it to
other family members it'll be a great
gift at people's birthday I hope and
Christmas
my grandfather is just the little essays
he'd written and printed off on on
printer paper and handed to family over
the years when put all in one place
ran to 328 hardcover pages we had no
idea it amounted to that much material
and so I was able recently to surprise
my father I had not told him about this
project by giving him a professionally
printed hardback of his own father's
writings that looked like a
professionally typeset book even though
as I admit it to him it was really time
set with Python thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much condom okay we have
a few minutes for questions now in the
audience you know if you want to
disagree with me on typesetting I'm
delighted to thank you very much for
this talk I'm delighted to hear it
because I've been using tech for about
twice as long as I've been using Python
and this is probably the best attended
talk on digital typography in the world
this year and perhaps the year before
the only thing I think that can rival it
will be Don Knuth 80th birthday
celebration which was surely well
attended
so my I'm sorry I don't have a question
[Laughter]
thank you
Thank You Brendan that was really very
lovely and I have just a quite a banal
technical question I'm very sorry when
you received the original
material that your grandfather wrote
presumably it was written in something
like word or something like that I guess
in raw
okay so it already had good markup forth
I wouldn't the day's answer that you
needed so his question was how was my
grandfather's essays marked up one or
two of them were in a sort of a quirky a
format most of them had been written on
his UNIX PC in a format called in Roth
which you can if you go look at the
source code to any UNIX man page in Roth
is the system of markup Bell Labs 1970s
markup to market paragraphs and bold and
italics and headings the main problem
with it is that it's more a styling
language than a markup language it
typically doesn't say unless you're
using the macros
a man page natively in Roth doesn't say
here's a heading
it just says Oh make these words bold
and so I had to write a Python script
that I had to kind of learn his
conventions all right when there's a
line by itself that's bold I will
interpret it as a heading when there is
a line with automatic indentation I will
interpret it as formatted poetry because
he included my
great-great-great-grandfather who
started a small sawmilling town in
southern Alabama in his old age would
set and write poetry we don't even know
how he learned that there was such a
thing and so I just had to learn which
in Rauf command he tended to use before
normal paragraphs and before poetry and
so it has more special cases I think
than any other code I've ever written
any more questions yes so uh when will
your grandfather's memoirs be in book
stores I would need to find an agent and
I would also need to make sure that
everyone is dead because he wrote very
candidly about what it was like growing
up in the segregated south he talked
very candidly about how different
ethnicities within Birmingham different
white ethnicities were divided and while
I think that that everything he says is
very friendly and well-meaning there are
events he recounts that might embarrass
sons and daughters of other family
members or he had a he developed strong
friendships with other Boy Scouts and
some of the portraits of them are of
people more racist than the average
person in Birmingham and
in 1935 and so to publish the complete
essays I would have to make sure that
that no one was still alive who might be
embarrassed by the way that their
parents were portrayed or I guess I
could try to anonymize those scenes but
so some things are up on my website if
you go look on the website from the 90s
I've had some of his essays about the
oldest history of Alabama up there and
distant family members have sometimes
contacted me because they learn the
names of their great and great-great
grandfather's from those essays but some
of them will probably have to remain
unpublished until I'm sure that that
anyone who might be implicated or
parents might be implicated either
wanted them published or was gone so I
guess the the next keynote is gonna be
insuring everybody's dead with Python
but my question is because we have to
ask the important questions where all
the dashes the write dashes in Rauf did
not give him the full palette of dashes
and so as i as editor went through
fixing spelling mistakes and rectifying
things that needing correction i assured
that all of the dashes were correct
dashes in some cases my Python script
could just do it automatically if the
things to each side of the dash are
digits I turned it into an N - otherwise
I had to know whether it needed to be a
hyphen or an M dash which I had to do
manually this is gonna be a last
question last question so are you
intended to just release this as a
library or I do have ideas about how to
plummet into existing markup languages
I was planning so there is at the moment
as far as I know no lingua franca
between markup languages by which an
implementation of markdown and an
implementation of restructuredtext agree
to express themselves in some neutral
equivalent term heading paragraph
paragraph so I think that it would need
not just for markdown but for each
particular markdown library because
there's a you probably I would choose a
major one and it would probably just
need a little bit of custom Python code
that spoke to that particular markdown
library because while I could choose to
try to choose one format to represent
them all and ask one of those markdown
translators to move everything over to
that generally there's impedance
mismatching that can miss nuances so
probably custom code to talk to markdown
custom code to talk to restructure text
might work best a good question thank
you thank you all very much
[Applause]
you